قال وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبيه
لجونغ فو انه تم الاتفاق مع وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لودوستن على مراجعه استراتيجيه
الردع بشان تهديدات كوريا الشماليه في
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك عقب محادثات جماعه
وصفها باستفزازات كوريا الشماليه
وتقويضها للاستقرار
التزام بلاده باتخان اجراءات الردع
التقليديه والنوويه لحمايتك كوريا
الجنوبيه
مراسلنا محمد البقالي محمد في التفاصيل
هذا الاتفاق بخصوص مراجعه استراتيجيه
الردع بخصوص تهديدات كوريا الشماليه
كلمه السر مريم هي استعمال السلاح النووي
هذه المره الولايات المتحده تقول انها
تدافع عن حلفايا في المنطقه وهم اساسا
كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان
وتقوم بما يسمى بالردى خطه الردى لم تعود
تشمل فقط الاسلحه التقليديه ولكنها ايضا
تشمل
ناس كثيره الدفاع الامريكي اليوم في هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي بحيث اكد بان خطه الرد على
الامريكيه همم هنا في هذه المنطقه تشمل
الاسلحه التقليديه وتشمل السلاح النووي
وذكر بما تملكه او بما تضع الولايات
المتحده رهن اشاره حلفائها في القاعده
العسكريه الامريكيه هنا 28,000 جندي وعلى
وتر على ذلك طائرات اف 35 وطائرات
المراقبه يو اثنين بالاضافه الى استعداد
الامريكي معلن لاستعمال السلاح النووي اذا
اقتضى الحال لماذا هذا الحديث المتكرر
الان على السلاح النووي اللي بكل بساطه
لان كوريا الشماليه مع نهايه السنه
الماضيه وبدايه هذه السنه في استراتيجتها
العسكريه الجديده اعلنت اولا همم او اتمنى
خطه تقوم على امكانيه توجيهات ضربات
الوقائيه النوويه وهذا جاء على حلفاء
الولايات المتحده كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
اساسا تحت مخاوف وهواجيز كبيره مين ارتكاب
او من قيام كوريا الجنوبيه بتوجيه هذه
الضربات الوقائيه وهذا هو الذي يثير
المخاوي اكثر اي بمعنى ان هذه الضربات قد
يتم توجها بدون ان تكون هناك حرب سابقا
هذا من جيا من جهه ثانيه كوريا الشماليه
تقول انها في استراتيجيه العسكريه الجديده
انها ترغب في امتلاك اكبر ترصانا نوويه في
العالم وهذا الامر يثير مخاوف كبيره ايضا
هناك هذا في طبيعه الحال دافع حلفاء
واشنطن الى الاستنجاد بها وكان الجواب ان
استراتيجيه الرد ستوسع لتشمل همم السلاح
النووي والرساله هنا موجهه ايضا لكوريا
الشماليه وهذا الامر اعلنه الرئيس الكوري
الجنوبي في وقت سابق عندما قال انه في
اللحظه التي يتم فيها استعمال السلاح
النووي من قبل كوريا الشماليه فان نظام
همم
كامل وهذا يعني دخول المنطقه في مغامره
غير محسوبه هناك ايضا رغبه اخرى من
الولايات المتحده ومن حلف الناتو لانه لا
يجب ان لا ننسى ان زياره الوزيره الدفاع
الامريكي جاءت يوما واحدا بعد زياره
الاميره العام لحلف النايته وهي ربط
الصراع في هذه المنطقه بما يحدث ايضا في
الغرب بحيث ان المخاوي فالان او هناك رغبه
في ايجاد هذا الترابط ما بين الوضع الامني
في منطقه شرق اسيا وفي همم في منطقه حلف
النيه والحديث اساسا على الحرب على
اوكرانيا الامين العام لحل الفنيته سبق
البارحه طالب من كوريا الجنوبيه بتزويد
اوكرانيا باسلحه واكد هذا الامر بشكل واضح
ان الامنه متبادل سواء تعلق الامر من
الجانبين وكل طرف يؤثر على الاخر في
المجمل هناك سلاح نووي يدخل على الخط
وهناك رغبه في الربط بين منطقه شرق اسيا
من حرب في اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك محمد البقالي من صول